Here's a simple site, Skinny Ties.
I've opened up Dev Tools
in another window, so
when I resize this, you'll see
the resolution show up right here.
And like any responsible,
responsive designer,
I'm starting with a small mobile design.
This one looks pretty clean.
I'll start expanding and at 480 pixels,
I hit the first break point.
There are now two columns, there are bow
ties and pocket squares next to each
other, okay and at larger than 690
pixels, there are three columns, nice.
Once the view port is larger than 915
pixels, all of the fonts get bigger,
which is a pretty nice touch.
I also noticed a few other small
changes as the page was getting larger.
After you watch this video,
maybe you can check out Skinny Ties, and
try to find them.
I also took a look at
CNN.com's new layout.
This one is a bit more complicated.
Once again, I am starting small.
Notice the hamburger icon in
the top right-hand corner.
Clicking on it makes
the nav bar show up.
That's pretty nice.
Also notice that there are social media
icons underneath this main story.
I've expanded the page larger
than 725 pixels across, and
now these social media icons are gone,
unless you hover over.
This would be use something that
would be called a minor breakpoint.
Which isn't a huge page layout change,
but
there's still something
slightly different.
I've expanded the page
past 800 pixels wide, and
I see that the hamburger icon is gone.
There's more room at
the top of the page,
so as a result, the navigation menu
options are just showing up here.
Larger than 935 pixels,
the layout really changes.
With the extra screen real estate,
a few sentences about the main
story show up over here, and all of
this description is now on the right.
Notice the social media icons,
are once again showing by default.
Larger than the classic 960 pixel width.
The new screen real estate is being
taken up by other top stories for today.
And I found one more small break point.
Larger than 1024 pixels, an ad shows up.
All in all, not a bad design.
So now, it's time for
you to think about break points.